so this week my subscriber count has
gone up to 66,000 and pass all the way
to sixty six thousand seven hundred and
so as it was sixty six thousand six
hundred and something I started to get
the inevitable comments about 666 and
how you know his subscribers is 666 and
so I thought hey why not
it seems like it would be a good
opportunity to to do a video on the the
number of the beast 666 now of course I
will not be able to completely exhaust
the meaning the Book of Revelations is
an extremely dense book and there's so
much going on in it that I can't be able
to exhaust what is there regarding the
beast and the Antichrist and the two
beasts and the and the prostitute and
all there's so much going on but so I'll
try to to be a little dense in terms of
stay within the subject of 666 and say
as much as I can knowing that whatever
it is that I say here is not the final
word on anything
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
it's one of the reasons why it's
interesting to look at the number of the
beast 666 in terms of symbolism is there
are a lot of things we can get from it
one of the things is we can get a lesson
on how to do symbolic interpretation and
how symbolism affects the world let's
say and so if you want to understand 666
the way the best way to do it is to go
back and to look at where the number
appears in the Old Testament or in other
places in the Bible and then you can see
if there's a pattern among the different
places where these numbers appear and
how it can help you understand what 666
is referring to and so another way to do
it is also to look into the Church
Fathers and so the one of these several
of the early church fathers especially
Saint Irenaeus of Leo and Saint high
politics of Rome discussed this the
Antichrist and the notion of 666 what it
could mean and they follow the same
pattern so what they do in their text is
go back into Scripture and try to see
where some of these patterns occur where
there are similar occurrences so to help
them understand 666 now one of the
things at the outset that it's important
to talk about is one of the one of the
things I've told you before is that
symbolism acts as a kind of let's say as
the pattern of reality sometimes what
happens is you get variation on the
edges and what with time the variations
tend to snap back to the pattern so
sometimes you'll see modifications and
stories all your or you'll see
specifications which are there to bring
the pattern back or to emphasize the
regularity of the pattern that seems to
be what apocryphal writing does for
example where if in a story there is a
basic pattern in the Bible and
the pattern is there but it might not be
crystal clear for those who don't see
these things apocryphal stories later
will emphasize some aspect will add some
details to help you understand for
example that if in the when Christ was
born it says it only said that he was
laying in a manger now that is an
important symbol but in very very early
traditions it says that he that the
manger was in a cave and the stable was
a cave and so it's like okay you have to
understand the major manger in
relationship to the cave and to the axe
and acid the arcs which are not
mentioned in Scripture but which are
there in tradition and all of those
patterns are there in the manger but
adding these details on the side giving
us details on the side help us to
understand what is already there in the
text now one of the things that happens
for happen for example at the beginning
of Christianity is that there were
actually two textual traditions about
this number of the beast and revelations
one some text read 616 and some other
text read 666 666 and what happens is
st. Irenaeus of Leo tells us he says no
what is preferable is 666 this is that
this is the real tradition and what it
does is it snaps the pattern back into
place and so when now you look at the
number 666 it can help you understand
what is what it's referring to in terms
of the the number of the beast why that
number in particular why is that number
so important
there are many modern interpreters who
want to relate the the number of 616 and
666 to emperor Nero and I think there's
some relevance to that like it's not
completely irrelevant to think of it
that way but we have to be careful not
to reduce things to that as well you see
it's interesting in Irenaeus I think
it's in hyppolit cent hypothesis of Rome
where he talks about partial
accomplishments of a prophecy and then
he says there might have been partial
accomplishments
prophecies in the past but then there
will be the fullness of the
accomplishment in the future you can
understand that as here's the pattern
and there are manifestations of this
pattern and then there will be a final
total revelation of the pattern in the
end when everything comes together in
the end so so let's look at 666 and what
makes it so interesting in the
scriptures what it talks about is that
the the the beast will there are two
beasts there's a beast which comes out
of the sea and there's a beast which
comes out of the earth and the Beast
which comes out of the sea is like a
more powerful beast I'm not going to go
into all the details the Beast which
comes out of the earth is like a
secondary beast but the the secondary
beast of the earth is wants everybody to
worship the first beast and creates an
image of the first beast and breathes
life into this image and makes the image
speak and that convinces everybody
everybody is impressed and those who
don't worship this image of the beast
there they're there they're punished
they're killed and then the the second
beast has placed on people's hands on
people's foreheads the name or the
number of the beast which is given as
666 and it says that it is the number of
a man and so the church fathers
understood that as the number of a man
in the sense of how ancient languages in
Greek and in Hebrew especially in Hebrew
but you can kind of do it in Greek the
numbers the letters in the alphabet
corresponding to numbers and so each
name would have a numerical value you
know that's what we call gamma tria that
is the capacity to mathematically
interpret text through the way that the
the sums of the words or the sums of the
letters come together and create
mathematical value it's not a type of
interpretation which Christians do a lot
of these days but in the early church if
you read Irenaeus and you
hi politics and other early church
fathers they do tend to dabble in that
kind of reading and so the idea that it
is the number of a man and then urine AS
gives us some possibilities of names
interestingly enough there's one name
that I cannot understand what it refers
to avanthi or even this you wouldn't a
went this I don't know what that I can't
really understand what it would refer to
the two other names that he gives
tighten and latinus are extremely
relevant because the one refers to the
ancient gods that are you know pushed
out on the margins and were referred to
we're connected to some of the early
church fathers to the Nephilim before
the flood this idea of this mixture of
angels and-and-and men which created the
monsters and the other name latinus is
of course related to Rome now it is
obvious that all of this seems to be
talking about Rome and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna take you through the steps and
slowly you're gonna start to see the
pattern so it seems obvious that this is
talking about Rome there is a
relationship between Rome and Babylon in
terms of the [ __ ] there's also a
relationship to Rome in terms of the
Beast which has with it seven heads like
the seven hills of Rome and so there's
trying to show this relationship between
Rome the Beast also the [ __ ] which is
sitting on the Beast all of these things
are definitely related and so if you
look at the number 666
Irenaeus goes back into the Old
Testament and he looks at the places
where these types of numbers appear and
what he related to is first of all he
relates it to the six hundred years of
Noah that is Noah lived for six hundred
years and he also relates it to the and
he says that 666 is let's say an image
of all the the horrible things all the
the perfidy all
of the the blasphemy which occurred
within the six thousand years of
creation you have to understand the way
the ancients thought is that the
creation last was six days and then
there was the day of rest the the years
of Noah were six hundred years and then
there was the flood and the whole world
last six thousand years and then it's
the end of the world so you have to
understand it that way that is there is
there there that this six happens is
related to the notion of man is related
to the idea of the sixth day of creation
that's the key that's really the key to
understanding 666 is to understand it as
the sixth day related to the sixth day
of creation that's why he goes and says
the six hundred years of Noah and then
also the six thousand years of creation
so you can see this pattern embedded
structures we've talked about this all
the time embedded within themselves now
then Irenaeus also relates the 666 to
the statue which was built by
Nebuchadnezzar in the story of Daniel
that statue was 60 cubits high and 60
cubits across and the connection is
important because in Revelations it
talks about how the the second beast
makes an image of the first beast and
then breathes life into it and asks
everybody to worship it and so the fact
that he would connect that to the statue
of Nebuchadnezzar is of course extremely
coherent because in the story of
Nebuchadnezzar the King has the statue
built and asked everybody to worship it
and those who don't worship it get
thrown into the fire so we have now the
we have now the the six related to the
six days of creation related to this 600
years of Noah the 6,000 years of the
world and also this stat
- also related to Rome and to the Titans
these descendants of in biblical let's
say in early Christian thinking which
would have been related to the
descendants of Cain which have mixed and
have created these these monsters okay
so as you see I'm trying to kind of take
you along on this path to help you see
how if you look at the different
elements and you look at what the father
say and you look at what is in Scripture
you start to see how these things are
connected today now the one thing that
makes it difficult for people to
understand 666 is that they tend to see
it as like this dark ominous thing as
and you see it like in heavy metal
aesthetics this kind of dark image you
know subversive all this stuff but that
if you see it that way you're gonna miss
out on what 666 is because 6 is the
symbolism of 6 has more to do with a
kind of let's say fullness of creation
it has to do with the fullness of the
six days and so the full cycle is seven
days that is the complete cycle is seven
days but that completeness includes rest
includes the part that can't be
calculated includes the part that
doesn't work include the the margin the
buffer all of this stuff that I'm
telling you I've been talking to you
about now the six is the days of work
and so they are related to man and to
the notion of the the days of work so
you can hopefully you can already start
to see let's say that the problem you
could say is that metier in his book he
gives us a thing there are so many
things in met use book which I said so
simply but actually give us some
wonderful keys in order to understand
how how
the world works matured gives us the the
key to the circle and explains that if
you use the radius of a circle to
measure a circle you get six lengths and
then you get a seventh length which is
not which is a remainder which is not
part of the six measurements and that
seventh day
that's the completeness not the
coherence but the completeness the
totality which includes the fringe which
includes all those things that can't be
counted and so that's what seven
represents it represents completeness
six represents a kind of perfection of
work and so that is why the symbolism of
six and the symbolism of 666 is not a
dark symbolism it's actually a symbolism
of light you know and there are reasons
why for example the devil is represented
as an angel of light is because it is
the pride of light it is the pride of
work it is the pride of accomplishment
which gives you something like the
statue of Nebuchadnezzar which is to
think that man is everything to think
that great reason that that our capacity
to accomplish is all you know it's kind
of like the Tower of Babel that is what
the six refers to in its negative
connotation of course six is not
negative or nor is 666 but the negative
aspect of something like 666 would
really be a kind of a kind of perfect
system you can imagine a system which
the people think is completely worked
out and has everything in it despite
that it's lacking the it's actually
lacking the rest part it only has the
work part in it and so you can
understand why it has to do with control
and in the scripture it has to do with
control of Trey
and so you have this notion that it's
all it's about calculating it's about
accounting for and so you have this idea
that if you are not if you don't have
the sign of the beast on your hand or on
your forehead then you cannot
participate in the counting you can't
participate in the the world of exchange
you know and so it ends up being in its
negative aspect a an image of control
now it's it's interesting because
there's another place in scripture where
666 appear there are two actually other
places one is 666 appears in the place
where it says that Solomon encountered
the Queen of Sheba and had this
interaction with her and then it says
that the Solomon gave her a bunch of
stuff and the Queen of Sheba went back
to her land okay so the this foreign
princess this foreign entity this
unaccounted-for entity goes back to her
land and then it says the amount of gold
that Solomon acquired at the end of the
year was 666 talents so your intuition
is right away going to see that there's
a relationship there's a relationship
between the idea of trade because
Solomon got that money you know from
trading with the the people from from
Lebanon from the different from people
from tyre and all these different people
and so you have this idea that at the
end of the year this is what Solomon
counted and that is the notion of
counting this idea of accounting for
everything all that having a system
which is which we think is really which
is the totality of all and so and so
helping you understand that can help you
understand you know I mean people have
the Intuit have had their intuition
about this before you know when I
remember when I was young people talked
about how you know 666 was going to be
like a microchip that people put in your
hand and or your forehead whatever and
then when you read it then if you don't
have that then you won't be able to
trade and you know I don't the intuition
is actually pretty good in terms of
symbolism because it is the idea that if
you don't have your identity accounted
for then you cannot you cannot
participate in the trade you cannot
participate in the world so the queen of
sheba goes away and then there is just
this notion that there's this
completeness that is there and so on the
one hand that is why solomon was able to
build the temple to build this this
image of the holy city was able to build
the the structure of worship that's the
positive side but on the negative side
it was also the the problem of let's say
trying to account for everything that
brought solomon into into into a gave
Solomon the problem because there are
certain aspects of reality which you
should not account for in Scripture it's
the Sabbath in Scripture it's the
Jubilee in Scripture it's the corners of
the field that you have to leave for the
foreigners that you don't you don't want
to count you don't want to gather the
corners of the field you also want to
leave a fringe on your investment you
don't want to completely tie up the
knots of your clothing completely close
the system and so the problem that
happens is when you try to account for
everything that's when you get this
insane system this insane system which
create a weird tyranny of the exception
trying to account for the exception you
know when we see the explosion of all
the marginal identity is the the kind of
or the explosion of the recognition of
all these marginal identities what we're
seeing is the process of something like
this notion of of 666
and you see it not just in that sense
but in the sense that for example you
could account for consciousness
completely an image of this of course is
in the vision of artificial intelligence
and so it's interesting because there
are a lot of these things kind of
swirling around today which can help us
understand the problem of 666 I know
some of you many of you have probably
seen the the speech that Tim Cook gave
to the ADL the CEO of Apple if you have
not seen it it is very much worth your
time to watch it because when he he he
himself embodies wants to portray
himself as embodying these marginal
identities and then what he talks about
is the creation of an artificial
intelligence which he literally can't
use that word anymore which he which he
which he describes as the God out of the
machine and that we have to create this
God out of a machine and this God out of
the machine will solve our problem the
problem of hate speech the problem of
hate in general the problem with
excluding these marginal identities and
so he wants to account for everything
and he believes that he can create an
image of man and that he somehow believe
that he will be able to breathe life
into it so that it becomes this
consciousness and that this
consciousness will then be put up above
us as an authority and will decide for
us who know who is excluded and who is
included and and in the desire to
actually include all the margin and so
in order to include all the things that
should not be accounted for that should
exist on the fringes in terms of this
kind of potentiality and in terms of
these exceptions and all of this we want
to now contain it all and we want to
control and those who won't bow down to
this image of man to this this golden
image will not be able ultimately to
participate in
system will be exclude those are the
ones who will be excluded from the
system not the not the the not the
marginal identity is not the exceptions
all of this but those who will not
recognize the totality of their system
that their system accounts for
everything those are the ones will be
excluded and will be thrown out you know
and that's that's the whole image of
idolatry that's the whole image of pride
itself is the problem of believing that
it all stops here
all of it stops here and you can
recognize that you can celebrate and
ultimately that you worship we know the
image of the image of man that you
worship reason that you worship science
and you worship technology all of these
things or it seems like as we look at
where the world is going that we are
potentially at least going in that
direction
you know in terms of the trading we've
already seen it and we've already seen
how creating this system of of of
controlling everything you know when we
have these online banks and credit cards
and all of this we end up having a a
perfect system you could call it that
that if it becomes let's say if it
believe it is self-sufficient and it
won't see its own ideology we'll be
willing and we've seen it happen in the
past two years exclude certain people
from participating it because they don't
recognize this Idol they don't recognize
this Idol so I think that that's really
important to understand in terms of the
the the image of 666 and just to kind of
let's say support my theory I think it's
important to look at the number itself
and understand you know 666 what is it
as a number it's actually an extremely
powerful number it takes actually it's
actually an image of let's say it's a
it's an image of perfection to to to a
very strong degree and there are many
reasons why it's that way the first
reason is six itself is extremely
powerful because it is
No one plus two plus three equals six
and so the first three digits with the
very important ones which is unity
duality multiplicity those are the one
two three that's what they symbolize so
if you add those up you get six and
that's so it's a very important number
not only is it the sixth day of creation
but even mathematically it has a lot of
power and has a lot of importance now if
you look at 666 for example I can just
show you how powerful it is how it's
like 666 is like 6 on steroids you can
call it something like that and so it's
6 times 6 is 36 right but if you take
from 1 to 36 and you add them up you go
1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 all the
way to 36 you get 666 and so if you add
all the digits up to 36 you you get 666
and 36 is 6 times 6 so there's a lot of
stuff happening in those numbers now the
last aspect which when I talk about how
666 is a is is a symbol of light and is
not a symbol of Darkness light in the
bad sense in the sense of
self-sufficiency right we've talked
about this the sins on the right hand
since of pride and all of that is that
that 666 is one of the most famous magic
squares if you there is a very I guess
but from people who know about this
stuff a very famous magic square which
has is a 6x6 square in which if you add
each column you get 111 and if you add
each row you also get 111 and if you add
it all up you get 666 and so there is
this extremely if you if you even see it
visually you can see that it is this
square this kind of image of perfection
and this image of perfection of work is
what is the way that I explain it or
let's say cause of extreme coherence and
so it's very it's very powerful in that
sense and so we have to be very
attentive because
these patterns play themselves out as
these patterns start to appear to us in
the world.we we have to not look for the
the ozzy osbourne you know dark Satanist
who is going to you know be wearing all
black and and look like a ghoul coming
out of the earth that is not what 666
looks like 666 looks like a luminous
system that seems like it contains
everything and that can control
everything and and that has everything
in itself and that is why it is so
seductive and that it is why it can
delude us if we're not careful and
because to not participate or to not
let's say worship this system can make
you excluded from from the discourse it
makes it a very it makes it very easy to
compromise in that sense and so
hopefully as we hopefully things will
not get worse this is really my hope but
as we've seen in the recent few years
even credit cards and some banks deny
access to to people and understanding
that I told you this has to do with
counting and when it says the number of
a man of course the Church Fathers
interpreted as counting the name of the
man but it's also the number of man that
is six is the number of man and man's
activity and so when we see these human
systems that are all controlling and
that is when we have to be careful and
be suspicious especially if we see them
start to exclude people from
participating them because they don't
acknowledge the truth of their narrative
let's say it's very dangerous and so
hopefully this will give you a little
hint on the 666 we're already at half an
hour for this video I don't want to go
too much into it there would be a lot
more to talk about in terms of
understanding the city understanding
Rome the relationship to the temple the
relationship also to the city as being
you know this image of the Titans cane
you know Edom Rome there's so much to
talk about maybe at some point I can
talk about those other relationships but
hopefully it will give you at least some
food for thought and you know as we are
in the month of November we are gonna
deal with a little bit of these dark
subjects again I decided that for my
November patreon video I'm going to be
making a video on which is and witches
is also an extremely wide subject and
difficult to cover in one video
and so I'll mostly be trying to look at
the book the hammer of witches the
malleus Maleficarum and look at what the
people in that book said witches we're
trying to accomplish and whether or not
that what they say has happened or
whether it succeeded whether it failed
so we'll we'll have some fun with that
and also after this dark moment as
Christmas is approaching my children
insisted this year that I make a t-shirt
which was obviously Santa Claus exist
they all wanted one and so I decided
with my kids and I put it up on
teespring so if you're interested in
proclaiming the truth about Santa for
the holidays you can go ahead and check
that out
so guys thank you for your support I've
seen a lot of growth in the viewership
of the channel so I really appreciate it
as usual you know share the video if you
think it's worth it and I will see all
of you
[Music]